We've already spoken to you about
the importance of user feedback.
Learning from and responding to
feedback is incredibly important.
But now, let's hear from the expert
about their real world experience using
feedback to learn about their customer's
needs and to better their product.
>> So
I am VP of mobile a UserTesting, and
UserTesting is a company that let's
you get really, really fast turn
around videos of normal people
using your application or website.
So you come to us, you define the test
you need, the demographics, and
you get videos back often
in as little as an hour.
So it's a really fast turnaround.
So what you can learn on the marketing
side is getting more insights into
what's going on in the heads of your
customers and how well are you matching
what's happening in what
they're thinking about.
So it can be early stages when you're
working on your marketing materials,
testing it out on people, finding out
what sorts of things they respond to
well and which things they don't like.
Or it can be later on,
after you've launched when
you're looking at analytics or
things like that and trying to get
more insights on the behaviours that
you're seeing in what
customers are doing.
So times when you can use user tests
just alone, there are two categories.
One is when you're really interested
just in understanding emotional context,
because analytics won't
give you that stuff at all,
it's like how are they feeling about it,
are they feeling engaged,
are they interested, are they feeling
like they're making progress?
And sometimes when I watch the videos,
I actually just look for
tone of voice more than anything else.
So for example, if you're testing an app
and at some point during the test,
the user sighs, they do this [SOUND],
you know you're in deep, deep trouble.
I mean,
it could be a in foreign language.
If you just hear, or the tone of voice
is, well, you kind of get that trailing
off tone of voice, what that is telling
you is that you are failing to grab them
emotionally which means you are not
creating the motivation which will cause
them to come back in the future
to use your app again and
you've really got a problem
that you need to go dig into.
I think the second place where
the user test can stand alone is when
the conclusions are so clear that, hey
we don't need [LAUGH] analysis on this,
it's really obvious what's going on.
And one class of these is when you find
that there's particular language or
maybe an icon design or something like
that that just doesn't work for them.
And a lot of times, because the team
has been working on the app for
a long time, you get this kind
of group think situation where
because it's become clear to you over
time that this is how it should work, or
this is what the context
of this stuff means,
this phrase is very meaningful to
the team for describing the application,
therefore, it's gotta mean
the same thing to the users.
And what you'll find very often is it
is not intuitive to them and actually,
you need to step back and
get inside their head and
the user test can show you that
sort of stuff very quickly.
If the icon is not intuitive,
they'll just look at it and
say, what the heck am
I supposed to do here?
And that's the point where you need to
think about, okay, either redraw it or
maybe add a text label,
which is not sexy,
it doesn't look beautiful, but we're
after usability more than we are beauty.
I mean,
it's great if you can get both, but
I'd rather have it be usable first and
then pretty it up as much as you can.
The user test can be a great way to
very rapidly get those insights, so
you can fix them right in the moment.